[موسيقى]
الان عبر الكاميرا العربيه وواحده منها
عمليات الدمار هي اللي طائره الشحن وهي
اكبر طائره شحن في العالم وهي من نوع
تنوفي 225 والتي دمرتها طبعا هذه الطائره
التي تستطيع حمل اكثر من 250 طن من عمليات
الشحن وايضا يصل طولها الى اكثر من 84
مترا تحمل ست محركات كل محرك يزن اكثر من
خمسه الاف كلغ
من كوزن
[موسيقى]
من يشاهد الان هو النصف او مؤخره الطائره
اما امام الطائره والنصف الاخر الامامي هو
في الجهه المقابله الان وهي من الحطام
سواء مكسوره الطائره ومقدمه الطائره او
كذلك الجزء الخلفي بنسبه لها دمر في
الطائره
[موسيقى]
الحكومه الاوكرانيه قامت بعمليه اعاده
تاهيل وكذلك عمليه زفلته لهذا المدرج
وكذلك ايضا نشاهد فريق من شركه تقوم
باعمال الصيانه وترميم لهذه الطائره لعلى
ان تكون ان تعيد ما خلفته القوات الروسيه
من عمليه التجميل
[موسيقى]